- Well, hello.
We're in New York now where
our show's in New York.
I love it here.
Do you love it here?
- I can do five or six days.
- That used to be me.
- Yeah.
- I love the energy
of this city, I think that's what I love.
But we're almost to Valentine's Day
and you have like one of the
sexiest voices on planet earth.
(audience cheering and clapping)
So, just say,
if I'm making a Valentine's playlist,
what's the song you think
I should play of yours?
- Oh, oh, of mine?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- "Tonight's The Night."
- [Kelly] Yeah, good one.
- "Have I Told You
Lately That I Love You."
"The First Cut Is the Deepest."
- Yeah, oh, all of those.
- "I Don't Want to Talk About It."
- Shut up, your catalog.
- Yeah.
- I mean, and, whoops.
I said shut up.
Sorry.
But yeah, it was in a nice way.
- I'm used to it, don't worry, darling.
I'm used to it.
(audience laughing)
- You're married.
I cover a lot of Sam Cooke on the show
'cause he's one of my favorites.
And I hear we have that in common.
- Me too.
Yeah.
- Yeah.
What's your favorite?
- "Cupid, Draw Back To Your Bow."
- Okay.
- "A Change Is Gonna Come."
"Twistin' the Night Away."
- Do like "Lost & Lookin?"
- Oh, yes, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, tremendous.
He was a big influence on my
career when I was growing up.
- Yeah?
- That's the only guy
I wanted to sound like,
it was Sam Cooke, so.
- It's amazing to me that you wanted
to sound like anybody other than yourself
since your voice is so magical, but cool.
- But it wasn't, it didn't used to be.
It used to be horrible, you know,
but, so I had to mold my voice on someone.
So I listened to Sam
Cooke and Muddy Waters,
all the great black artists.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So if there wasn't Sam Cooke,
there may not have been a Rod.
- If there wasn't Muddy
Water, maybe no Beatles.
- [Rod] Easy peasy, you know.
- Yeah.
- It's not easy being me.
Well, you both have incredible voices.
But he's probably who I listen to most.
Like on vinyl when I'm like at my ranch.
- Always?
- Yeah.
- Whole lot 'cause you're a country girl.
- I live, well, no, I
grew up on everything.
I grew up on you, I grew up on everything.
I'm the last born, so I was the wild one
that liked everything from Metallica
to Rosemary Clooney into.
- That's a wide feel.
That's tremendous.
- Yeah, but I feel like we're similar
'cause you've covered all
the great standards as well.
Like, you--
- Yeah.
- Like I love all your music
and I also love when you
cover other people's songs
and then it's like,
"Oh, he did it better."
- Yeah.
- But what was like the
first song that moved you
that you felt like it
stirred something in you?
Do you remember?
- Oh, the real deep emotion's probably,
"Change is Gonna Come."
You know?
Sam Cooke and then he was killed.
It was killed a few days before
and afterwards, that was a big movie.
But the big one was for me,
changed my life, was
Bob Dylan's first album.
- Yeah.
- You know, I'd never been to America,
hadn't been to the other
side of the street,
you know, and that album.
- So it's kinda your first glimpse.
- Yeah, Bob Dylan's first album.
- Yeah, amazing.
Mine was, "Ain't No Way," Aretha Franklin.
- Yeah.
- I was like,
I didn't even really
understand 'cause I was a kid.
But even if you're a kid,
you understand like a great storyteller.
Like I was like,
I don't know what she's
really talking about,
but it was so moving.
- Yeah, got you there.
- Yeah, I love that.
I hear you're making whiskey these days.
Solid choice.
- Yeah.
- You got Scottish blood.
- I'm not making it myself.
- Yeah.
- But I'm, you know,
I'm the sort of face behind
the bottle as it were.
- Yeah.
- It's really, really good stuff.
Trust me.
- Yeah.
I'm gonna try it.
- You know, like a lot of whiskeys,
you go like that and you go, "Oh, (beep)."
Oops, sorry.
- Yeah, yeah.
(audience laughing)
- Sorry about that.
- You're on the right show.
- This is really, really--
- Smooth?
- Acceptable
and smooth almost.
- Yeah, I like that.
Okay, well, what's the
best rockstar you think
that you've hung out with
while drinking whiskey?
Because you look, last time you were here,
you left and I was like,
you have lived seven lives.
(Kelly laughs)
- Unrest.
- Your stories are incredible.
- Yeah.
Probably my dear friend,
Ronnie Wood, you know?
- [Kelly] Okay.
- We never were big
whiskey drinkers though.
But then I never was a whiskey drinker.
- Back in the day, yeah.
- I mean, I got into it because,
you know, I had a Scottish father.
I love everything about Scotland.
So it was the a natural move
for me to brand a whiskey.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It's called Wolfie's.
- [Kelly] Oh, I like that.
- Yeah, would you want some?
- Yes, I do.
The band, y'all want some?
- Yeah.
- Like, we're all game,
so, okay, well, we're gonna go over there
and we're gonna have a little drink
and we're gonna judge your whiskey.
In the meeting, I'm just kidding.
We have been highlighting Buskers
'cause we're new to New York
and there's a whole thing here.
And I heard that early on in your career,
like when you were younger, you busked.
Is that true?
- Yeah, yeah.
I was busked in Paris
under the Eiffel Tower
and in Spain in a football stadium.
- Oh, wow.
Yeah.
- Fans were coming in, I'd just
sing all me old folk songs.
So that's, you know, I was
about 15 or 16, I suppose.
- It's so crazy to me to
think that you were doing that
and people were like passing you,
like not knowing one day you'd be you.
- Yeah.
- That's insane.
I heard that.
Is this true, that a band mate,
that a future band mate
actually discovered you
in a train station?
You were playing harmonica?
- No, this was a guy that
discovered me, period.
- Oh.
- His name was,
Long John Baldry.
And he had a great blues band
and I used to go and see him
and I was playing harmonica
on Platform 2 and singing.
He was on Platform 3 and he came over
and asked me to join his band.
And so.
- [Kelly] That's incredible.
- Simple twist of fate.
- Yeah.
- And this same guy
discovered Elton John,
was in his band as well.
Long John Baldry.
- Is this guy in A&R or
like working with a label?
Like, he seems like he's
pretty good at finding talent.
- No, he's upstairs now.
- Oh, man.
Well, man, and how much he
blessed us with finding y'all.
- He did, yeah, he did.
Yeah.
- Wow, what a good ear.
So I heard that you keep saying,
"Oh, I'm leaving Rock
behind for right now."
I don't know, sir, that
that's ever gonna happen.
Like when you show up and
you just rock and roll,
you just ooze it.
- Yeah.
- It's not much else
I could have been with this face.
- No!
It's just you're so cool.
I mean, even like musically, like,
I think it's rock and
roll to just be like,
"Hell with it, I'm gonna sing
whatever I want at any time."
- Yeah, absolutely.
- So I love that
you're doing swing, right?
- Yeah.
- This is awesome.
Is this always been like a musical genre
that you love and--
- Yeah.
But the first question first,
I haven't left rock behind.
I want to get on with these jazz album
that I've made, the Swing album.
- Yeah
- Of course,
I did "The Great American Songbook."
So I wanna be able to
go and sing those songs.
- Absolutely.
Well, Sir Rod worked with
another very talented musician
on the new album.
Let's bring him out right now.
He is a legendary band leader, composer,
pianist, and television host.
Everybody please say
hello to Jools Holland.
(audience cheering and clapping)
(upbeat music)
You look very swing, man.
I love this whole vibe.
Your suit.
- I'm trying to go as
swing as I possibly can.
Exactly, yes.
It's so nice to be here with
this amazing man, isn't it?
- I know.
Well, I'm gonna start with that.
How did this happen?
Like how did y'all end up doing this?
- Do you wanna start or shall I?
- Yeah, I'll start.
I was trying to make this
swing album in Los Angeles
and it wasn't turning out so well
'cause it didn't have enough edge to it.
I wanted it a bit more rock and roll.
- Yeah.
- Bit scruffy.
So, I thought of him.
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- He said,
"I want some rough and ready."
I said, "Well, thank you,
you've come to the right man."
- [Kelly] Rough and ready.
- Yeah, 'cause I think this--
- [Kelly] So many jokes there.
- Yes, thank you.
Yes.
As I said earlier, if
there's any innuendo,
I like to whip it out straight away.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- So I think one of the
things that I really
couldn't believe was that Rod rang me.
- Yeah.
- Just before Christmas.
And listen, our paths had
crossed occasionally in music,
but I didn't know him so
well and he rang and said,
"Could you come and
do you wanna make a record with me?
One, and happy Christmas."
So I said, "Yeah, great, thanks a lot."
And that was, he said,
"I'll call you next year."
I thought it was a hoax call.
But then in the new year, he rang again.
It was absolutely true.
- Yeah.
- And he said,
"I want something, but I mean,
it's hard to put words on music,
but it's all those great songs,
but have got sort of
a little rock and roll
edgy tattiness to them.
That's not the right word.
But it's the feeling you get off them.
That's the thing. "
- Tattiness was pretty nice.
- Yes.
- I like it.
- Well, it was all words
that applied to me, I think.
- Yeah.
- So.
- Used them.
- Used them, and I was very
worried when we first did it,
when I've recorded the first
tracks, I got them ready,
and then he came in and he started dancing
and then I knew everything,
everything was gonna be okay.
- But that's what's so
beautiful about Swing in general
is you have to move.
You feel the music as well,
even if you're singing it
or playing it, it moves you.
And I think that joy and
music sometimes gets lost.
- That's exactly the word, joy.
And there's not so much.
A lot of music doesn't have joy in it.
And this music really does, doesn't it?
It's the most and it's been
a very happy experience.
Normally, you hear about
records, people say,
"Oh, you know, we had
a fight in the studio.
I've left music because of it.
It was the worst experience of my life."
This is the opposite.
It's been a pleasure.
It's been so easy 'cause all
the songs, we love the songs
and it is an expression of joy.
So, great.
- Is it true that y'all did
most of it live in the studio?
Like with the band?
- Yeah.
- I love that, I've only
done that like a few times
and God, it is amazing.
- Yeah.
- To be in a studio
and feel that.
- That's the way bands,
that's the way music used to be recorded.
You know, even in the '50s and '60s.
- Yeah.
- It was all done live.
But the only thing that
wasn't live was my vocal.
I had to have a few goes on
it, get used to the song.
Otherwise, it was all live.
- That's incredible.
- And it sounds it too.
- There is such a different sound
and you've been doing
swing for quite some time.
- Yes.
I mean, I was in this
band, Squeeze, and I left
and I started a big band in England.
- Yeah.
- And I realized, you know,
I had the ability to make
people dance early on,
I think, you know.
- Yeah.
- I mean,
all great musicians or great singers.
If Rod connects any song,
that's a great thing.
And I think if you are
me and a piano player,
you've gotta be able to
make people dance as well.
We did.
As an example, early on in the '90s
when my big band first got together,
we had a show where we did for the G8,
which is all the leaders
of the Western world.
- Yeah.
- So at that time,
it was President Clinton,
Prime Minister Blair
and all of the others.
- Oh, wow.
- And we got to do it and we decided--
- No pressure.
- No pressure, that's right.
Exactly, the world's watching
and a lot of security.
- Yeah.
- But
we thought we better end with
a song that unifies everybody.
So we did, "All You Need is Love."
So we play, the trumpet player plays.
- Yeah.
(Jools humming)
- At which point,
the French president thinks
that's a French national anthem.
So he stands up.
So then, I'm thinking.
- No.
- Oh, this.
And then Blair and Clinton,
both out of politeness,
they stand up 'cause it's
a French national anthem,
sort of doing this.
Then it goes into, "All You Need is Love."
But to avoid an incident,
and I don't know which one started it
and credit to him,
whichever one started it.
They all start doing this.
A bit of dad dancing, really.
It was dad dancing.
- Oh, my God.
I thought you were gonna be like,
so we broke out with the
French anthem and I was like,
"You just knew it?"
- It didn't bother.
No, no, but it was great.
And after all, all the world's dancing,
if they're all dancing, webs
are laughing, aren't we?
You know.
- Oh, my God.
That's hilarious.
What a great story.
And I would be sweating
if I were you to be like,
"Who knows the anthem?"
(audience laughing)
♪ What a day this has been ♪
♪ What a rare mood I'm in ♪
♪ Why it's all almost like being in love ♪
♪ There's a smile on my face ♪
♪ For all human race ♪
♪ Why it's almost almost
like being in love ♪
(audience cheering and clapping)
- And now we are back
with Sir Rod Stewart and Jools Holland!
(audience cheering and clapping)
So, once again we were speaking
of the joy it brings people.
Was that like impromptu,
like did you all like decide
you're just gonna show.
None of those people looked like they knew
y'all were gonna be there.
- No, we didn't know we were there.
- Yeah.
- It was a railway station in rush hour
and we just turned up, plugged
in, and started playing.
- I love it.
- Wonderful.
- It was great.
- Back to your busking.
- Yeah.
- I like it.
- More or less, yes.
Kelly, quite right there.
- That's amazing though.
Do you see how much joy you
were talking about that earlier.
- Yeah.
- And everybody's
just feeling it.
- But also, that song, you see that,
of all the songs on this
record we talked about,
well, I think of some, so we
just loved all of the songs.
This is the one song that I didn't know.
I mean, you can't know
everything, can you?
It's a (indistinct) so I didn't know.
But when, as soon as he starts singing it,
it became my favorite song.
You are a great singer.
You know this.
- Oh, I know that song.
Yeah.
- But when the singer
makes you realize, it is
the singer, not the song.
And he's the great singer.
And this was a particular special moment
when he first sang that.
- Yeah.
(audience cheering and clapping)
So you're saying that for the most part,
y'all agreed on songs or
did you each kind of bring
your own favorites to the table?
- Favorites to the table.
Yeah.
- Yeah.
- We didn't know.
There were no arguments.
- No.
- Oh, I love that.
We could have made another
album straight away.
- There's so much great music.
- Yeah, it is.
- And we both spent a long time living,
listening to and loving a lot of,
these are the great old American songs.
- Yeah.
- A couple of 'em
old English songs, but
most of 'em are great
old American songs.
And we've grown up with
all of that, hadn't we?
- Yeah.
- And just loved them.
- What was one that you like where like,
"This has to be on the album?"
What was that song?
- For me?
- Yeah.
- The first track.
"Lullaby of Broadway."
- Oh, I don't know that one.
- That was, yeah.
Yeah.
♪ Come on long and listen to ♪
♪ The Lullaby of Broadway ♪
- I do done that, yes, yes, yes.
♪ The hip hooray and ballyhoo ♪
- Oh, man, I don't think I
knew the name of it, but yes.
I know that song.
- Busby Berkeley.
What was the movie?
- Gold Diggers in 1930.
- Gold Diggers, yeah.
- Yeah, great.
- Yeah, when you send
Grave Digger a minute ago,
my brain said Gold Digger.
And I was like, "You were a what?"
- Gold Diggers.
- Literally,
that's where my brain went.
I was like, "I mean, you're owning it.
Okay."
I was like, "Good for you."
But anyway, you said Grave Digger.
I heard this crazy story.
I don't know if it's true,
but it's about.
Yes, with you.
With Sir Rod.
So the first time you
saw The Rolling Stones,
they were doing blues
music at like a little,
was it like a pub or theater?
What was it?
- Oh, it was a place
called, Eel Pie Island.
It was a little ballroom in Twickenham
and there was 12 people there.
- 12 people.
- 12 people, and mixed girlfriend.
It was a girl called Chrissy Shrimpton,
who's the sister of the
great model, Jean Shrimpton.
And my girlfriend, his
girlfriend were friends
and he said, "Come and see
my singer and my boyfriend.
He's a singer."
She said, "Oh, my
boyfriend's a singer too."
So I went over there and watched him.
There was literally nobody there.
And they were all sitting
on stools playing, you know.
- But they were doing like blues music?
- Yeah, oh, yeah.
- Yeah.
- Brian Jones was in the band then.
And then within six months
to a year, bash, that was it.
They took off.
- I mean, yeah, those
moments are just so cool.
- Yeah.
- Like once again,
like you busking and people not knowing
and then you sitting
there and not knowing like
what that band would become.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, it's incredible.
- I think the blues in
Britain was a big thing.
So, that's where I started as well.
The playing pubs playing blue stuff
'cause that's what we all heard.
That's it, it was a thing we,
you know, that you got
people were dancing.
- [Kelly] 'Cause it makes such an impact.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
Like here, like there's a lot
of music you just listen to
for fun, but not much that, I mean,
feels like really moves you.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, or that's what
I like to listen to.
But do you think you'll go
back to Vegas with this album?
- Mm, I'm just finishing up in Vegas.
My last, I've done 200
shows, so in August.
That's it.
(audience cheering and clapping)
- Great.
- That's a lot of shows.
- 200.
- Yeah.
- And you're gonna do shows
with Billy Joel as well.
- Oh, we're doing a show with Billy Joel.
Billy Joel asked me to join one show.
- That's amazing.
(audience cheering and clapping)
- In September at the
Cleveland Browns stadium.
- Oh, my gosh.
- But yeah, I love Vegas.
Love going there.
- Yeah.
- The people at Caesars Palace
are just wonderful.
- Agreed.
- It's the best place
you can see anybody.
Best seats, the best sound.
Everything.
- Intimate, isn't it?
It's intimate.
- It is intimate.
- It feels like it.
- Yeah.
No, I agree.
And I love--
- You played there,
didn't you?
- Yes, and I love going back,
my favorite, like whether
you're in a stadium or an arena
or whatever, my favorite is
always a more intimate like--
- Yeah, yeah.
- Five or less.
5,000 or less is my favorite.
I know, you play 5 million,
but I play like less
and I like that though.
Even like in the days
when I was like doing,
"Since You've Been Gone" like everywhere
and there were thousands
of people everywhere.
It's just so much better
for me as a performer
if it's more intimate in
like a theater environment
and you feel like you're
like talking with people.
I don't know, I feel
like it's kind of cool.
- Yeah, it is.
Yeah, absolutely.
- Yeah.
- Smaller places are better,
but they don't pay the bills.
- Yeah.
(audience laughing)
I am aware.
Let's hear it one more time, everybody,
for Jools Holland and Sir Rod Stewart!
(audience cheering and clapping)
The new album is called, "Swing Fever."
You can find it wherever
you get your music from.
February 23.